last time
i traveled to entebbe i'm sure i'm
butchering that name
in uganda i had to show evidence on my
who vaccination card of yellow fever
inoculation upon entry
why are people acting like this passport
is a new thing you know i actually
talked about this somewhat extensively
on bridgette fantasy's
uh podcast a couple weeks ago um so
i'm i'm not gonna go through it here but
um
basically uh one of the answers
is um well a few things
um being asked to be vaccinated to
travel someplace that is not your home
to protect the lives of the people who
already live there is very different
from being told that you may lose rights
and privileges to live in your own home
the way you've been living
before that said pandemic legitimate
pandemic does potentially change some of
that thinking
and the yellow fever vaccination is a
decades-old traditional vaccine with
literally decades of health and safety
data safety and efficacy data behind it
which makes it a very different vaccine
and you know this was my point actually
to bridget as well
you know i you know i had to and i had
to require all of my students
um to have yellow fever and some other
but yellow fever vaccination in
particular
that was the only one that i i i had to
get and we had to get and then i had to
require my students to get when i would
take
them deep into the amazon there's
literally a military checkpoint
where you show your card and if you
don't have it you get turned back
and frankly the responsibility
for you as someone coming into a space
to help keep the local population safe
is a very different situation yeah it is
a very different situation
um in effect you have the right to make
rules for people coming in
of course that makes sense uh right yeah
now um i would say also there is
i don't know anything about the business
behind the yellow fever vaccine but it's
such a tiny number of people who get
that shot
um every year especially as a result of
passports
and i don't know about vaccines but if
if if they're patented
the same way you know it's literally
been in production for many many decades
ago it must be out of patent i got it as
a kid
well no i i know it's been in use since
it's i can't remember now
it's been a couple of weeks but it's
like 1930s 1940s way before you were a
kid
so my point is i don't know if if
patents work differently for vaccines or
what but i don't think that there's a
huge profit to be made right i don't
think there's a huge profit to be made
because
you'll have lots of manufacturers and
the one thing i don't know is whether or
not the yellow vaccine is still the
yellow fever vaccine sounds like you
have established that it's the same
vaccine yeah
so anyway reverse incentives aren't
there history of
safety of the vaccine is clear yeah
um and so anyway and and it's
you know it's a requirement to go to x y
or z place
i should say require being required to
carry papers to walk around your own
country
that is um there's a lot of bad
historical precedent there
and it's it's you know it's not the same
as being forced to have a driver's
license to drive or to have a
yellow fever vaccination card to enter
you know ecuador or you know whatever
it's just not the same and we have
you know clear evidence
of perverse incentives and a massive
uh profit to be made for requiring
everybody i would also point if you'll
go back to
one of our early live streams we talked
about this
issue of what i called monkeying with
the baseline oh yeah
and um by forcing everyone to get
vaccinated they are also
monkeying with the baseline with respect
to our ability to establish what the
consequences
actually are that in effect if you did
have universal vaccination then you
don't have a control group so
it won't be quite universal but if they
can get close then
um then it also means we can't quite
test the question of what happened
yeah um
two more i think sort of follow-ups to
that question from the same person
or just comments um
boy it's actually two different people
uh with slightly different initials
um i so that person says i'd rather roll
the dice with my pfizer shots
than get covered and see those long-term
health effects they don't seem awesome
and then follows up with love bretton
heather i have a science undergrad and
social science masters i'm now a manager
my job is making many critical decisions
based on incomplete information
it's an art and a science and my gut
says just take the backs
so i would point out that
it's very hard to know what to make of
this result
that you just told me about for the
first time today i think you just
which one ran across it this result that
the spike protein in and of its brand
creates damage yeah it's it's a brand
new it's a model organism now it's
possible that that
is an anomaly it's possible that the
paper doesn't mean what we think it
means or that it
has to do with the model organism and
not people
but if it is true and i will say it has
the ring of truth because
it's not only that it does damage it
does exactly the kind of damage that we
see that is so anomalous with covid it's
consistent with it being vascular
disease and not primarily respiratory
right exactly so if that is the case
then think about what you're saying
right you're saying that a healthy
person
should take a dose of a
pathological
a pathological vaccine so i'm not saying
that this
is the case i'm saying if it is the case
then a vaccine that creates spike
protein that
itself induces damage is an acceptable
risk to avoid
the same kind of damage from the virus
now i'm not discounting how serious
this virus damage is it's very serious
and it has been practically a mantra
since the beginning of these live
streams people are underrating the
danger of kovid
because the death rate the case fatality
rate is low
right they are underrating the damage
because it's years of life lost from the
damage to major organs
that we see regularly in these cases
but that the vaccine is not it's you
know i think people have this sense
about
if i get away with it in the short term
then i got away with it and that's just
not how this works with a complex system
like this so
um i i hear you you may be right but you
need to leave open the possibility that
you're not right and that in fact
a a vaccine that itself does
significant damage to the body is
it's not a free pass